unser büro tempel der kreativität und
gleichzeitig des abfalls seit monaten
bauen wir hier hin und her und obwohl
super viel passiert ist kein ende in was
aber in den letzten monaten passiert ist
dass er jetzt ich wünsche euch viel spaß
mit dem umbau von tieren ich glaube
schon
[Musik]
nicht wahr
genau das darf doch wohl nicht wahr sein
nach anderthalb monaten hatten wir hier
wände eingezogen schränke bringen und
schreibtisch ansonsten aber nicht
besonders gefehlt hat noch um damit auch
thema dieses videos die gesamte
klimatisierung aller räume türen zu
allen büros und deckungsmöglichkeiten
jeglicher art pflanzen pflanzen an den
wänden pflanzen auf den schränken nudeln
machen wir haben man kann nudeln machen
kann technik und equipment ein lager um
sachen abzulegen weil wir keinen keller
und natürlich die lang ersehnte küche
oder irgendeinen übergang für unsere
kirche na dann mal los naja und bevor es
losgeht wenn euch solche umbauprojekte
spaß machen dann hab ich was für mich
nächste woche starten endlich mit der
ersten folge von ich habe eine wohnung
gekauft nur um sie für einen youtube
projekt zu renovieren ich habe die
schlüssel für die wohnung ich habe die
erste folge schon gedreht und das wird
so eine zehnteilige serie über die
nächsten monate hinweg sehr nice also
vergesst nicht zu abonnieren
erstmal haben max und ich uns nicht
lumpen lassen und unser absolutes kaum
sofa gekauft und haltet euch fest dieses
sofa hat gebraucht 9000 euro gekostet
warum das aber ein bisschen weniger
verrückte ist als es scheint erkläre ich
euch jetzt glauben sie dass ich verrückt
bin das sofa ist ein absoluter design
klassiker und verliert relativ wenig bis
gar nicht an wert je nachdem wie gut
linie gerade liefern kann und je nachdem
wie gut wie oft das so verachten das
sofa ist außerdem komplett modular und
besteht aus vielen verschiedenen
einzelteilen das bedeutet wiederum dass
falls sich dieses büro irgendwann
auflöst wie er das sofa auch einfach
aufteilen können teilweise verkaufen
oder auch komplett verkaufen können auch
in den letzten jahren konnte man schon
beobachten dass sowas dieser firma
beziehungsweise genau diese serie war
sie gar nicht an wert verliert deswegen
kann man davon ausgehen dass in den
nächsten jahren ähnlich aussehen wird
das bedeutet wiederum auf dass wir das
geld quasi nur im sofa geparkt haben und
es irgendwann wieder zurückkaufen können
im besten fall ich gehe aber davon aus
absatz von diesem ganzen thema finde ich
aber einfach das ist unheimlich schön
ist frisst sich richtig gut in unserer
fläche macht das ist nicht besonders
hoch crysis komplett modulare und weil
wir eh super viele freunde haben uns
kann mit den raum den kompletten großen
raum der hinter mir ziemlich einfach
umgestalten und einfach neue anordnung
finden und bevor wir uns jetzt um andere
sitzmöglichkeiten oder die
wandgestaltung kümmern erst mal zu einem
weiteren praktischen teil unser lager
wir haben nämlich keinen keller müssen
deswegen irgendwie in dieser fläche hier
lag das habe ich in der planung unseres
büros das rechte drittel in drei
einzelne 3 unterteilt das letzte drittel
was komplett richtung band geht wo auch
keine fenster sind habe ich dann noch
mal geteilt in einen streaming raum und
in einem durchgangslager durch das man
in den streaming raum kommt viele leute
von euch waren am anfang etwas skeptisch
mittlerweile sind wir aber super super
happy besonderer tag heute wird unser
lager fertig gestellt wir haben einen
schäfer lager egal so das beste vom
besten gekauft damit wir ruhe haben
einmal kaufen und dann für immer ruhe
und jetzt heißt es erstmal das
gebrauchte regal
[Musik]
wir haben uns tatsächlich etwas schwer
getan beim aufbau obwohl das system
eigentlich ziemlich einfach ist
insgesamt haben wir vier lagerabteile
welche jeweils ca eine tonne tragen
können auch wenn wir so viel natürlich
gar nicht brauchen ist es das zu haben
geplant ist dass hier langfristig super
gut sortiert alle equipment kleinteile
fein säuberlich gelagert werden und wir
alle akkus laden können und einfach nur
gute ordnung haben natürlich müssen wir
aber auch große sachen lagern die wir
jetzt nicht jeden tag brauchen aber
trotzdem da sein müssen wie staubsauger
unser server da auch mit drin liegt uns
auch gekümmert haben wir haben
serverstruktur lan-kabel diesen ganzen
quatsch hier auch jetzt endlich gemacht
und am ende ist es genau so geworden wie
ich mir vorgestellt habe ziemlich
praktisch sieht aber auch so cool aus
dass wir da drin drehen können sie ein
bisschen industrial stil ist immer noch
genug platz um den stream und raum zu
kommen alles wunderbar
untrügliche ein sehr leidiges thema sie
ist eigentlich max küche und seit
monaten auf dem weg und wir warten
darauf dass sie endlich kommt weil sie
auch so ein bisschen herzstück dieses
ganze büros ist deshalb die jungs und
mädels vom landwirtschafts simulator 22
pc games und logitech auch mitbekommen
und mir die aufgabe gestellt die fläche
doch etwas besser zu nutzen als gerade
tun dann benutzen sie gar nicht im
prinzip möchte ich eine indoor farm
bauen in der es verschiedene ebenen gibt
auf der zum einen tomaten erdbeeren und
salat angebaut werden
fertig ist die erste vertical farm
zumindest soweit hier oben kleine
pflanzen setzlinge hier nochmal kleine
pflanzen setzlinge und da unten sind die
großen pflanzen die dann richtig schön
wachsen und gedeihen können
[Musik]
hhg
wichtig und richtig
ein heuballen geil
ist sachen heute ein logitech g700 35
headset logitech g19 115 fast hat mit
bestem aus die ich selber benutze b 502
heavy equipment bandelt es ist ein mini
traktorreifen
halleluja games pc games unter anderem
landwirtschafts simulator und eine menge
anderen tollen kann den mit dem gamepad
zocken könnt
[Musik]
vielen dank noch mal an landwirtschafts
simulator 22 pc games und logitech die
das möglich gemacht haben nur durch
solche partner ist es mir möglich immer
größer und weiter zu denken und ich sage
das weil die nächste woche nämlich die
erste folge von ich habe eine wohnung
gekauft um sie zu renovieren kommt und
ich unheimlich pampin also vergesst
nicht den kanal zu abonnieren um das
nicht zu verpassen jetzt viel spaß
weiter mit dem video
nach dem lager ging es dann endlich
weiter mit unserer wandgestaltung und
wir erinnern uns zurück da gab es ja vor
12 monaten einige probleme eigentlich
war nämlich geplant dass ihr in der wand
direkt hinter uns jetzt schon eine
holzvertäfelung sieht das ist eigentlich
funktioniert weil das komplette material
ebenso auf dem weg vom hersteller zu uns
verloren gegangen ist das ist liebe
grüße und tatsächlich wurde unser
komplettes material wiedergefunden was
bedeutet dass wir endlich mit der
verteilung und einfärbung staaten
entschieden haben wir uns für bergmann
paneele diesen im prinzip so vereinfacht
zu installieren das habe ich natürlich
nicht alleine gemacht sondern mit
unserem bruder kreativ tobi alle links
sind in der video beschreibung da sind
ja auch ein komplettes video nur zu
dieser wand was tobi natürlich in die
most professional way für uns gemacht
hat
[Musik]
tobias haupt mal wie er leibt und lebt
unglaublicher übels geil es ist wie man
es von mir kennt in meiner sprache weise
ein absoluter traum allein und leo wenn
du einmal hier vorne zu mir hinkommt
haben wir jetzt ein neues set
mega mega happy damit wir haben jetzt
einfach super viele verschiedene
hintergründe die es uns super einfach
machen zu produzieren also im prinzip
vorstellen kamera und los geht das ist
megageil und da wir bis zu dem zeitpunkt
nur die möglichkeit hatten leute auf dem
sofa sitzen zu lassen was beim
mittagessen oder bei meetings natürlich
völliger quatsch ist haben uns endlich
dafür entschieden kurzen prozess zu
machen und einfach stehen weil ich her
zu kaufen nachdem wir zwei monate bei
einem onlineshop auf irgendwelche
besonderen studie gewartet hatten und
wir einfach keinen bock mehr die stühle
sind angekommen und wir bei uns jetzt
zusammen
[Musik]
ok also was haben wir kunstgewerbeschule
ton in ton optik und man könne extrem
gut sitzen meetings haben hoffen essen
essen
einfach alles perfekt ja aufmerksam
unter euch werden auch zwei weitere neue
sachen im hintergrund gesehen haben zum
einen eine green rollt echte pflanzen
konserviert die müssen also nicht mehr
gegossen werden oder so sondern hängen
für immer so wie sie sind sehr schick an
unsere wand und bringen etwas grünes
labour in unser beruf und natürlich
unsere komplett neuen auf uns
maßgeschneiderten glas loft türen meinen
uns die tür im alten büro so gut
gefallen hat wollten wir die auch gerne
in diesem büro wieder haben das hat auch
viel mäßig super gut gepasst weil wir
aber schon wussten dass wir schwarze
stühle und schwarzen tisch und so weiter
haben werden haben wir uns für beschläge
und tür farbe da auch für schwarz
entschieden und ich finde es sieht gut
aus und wisst bin ich ein freund von
einmal kaufen dafür richtig und für
immer ruhe haben wir haben die türen
extra anfertigen lassen genau auf die
höhe unserer fenster im büro das
bedeutet man kommt rein und man wird
nicht verrückt weil die türen die im
raum sind ein bisschen niedriger sind
als die fenster die zum gebäude gehören
das alles genau auf einer ebene und mega
gut und mega stimmig aus unser kleines
problem kind im büro die kleine
problemzone war der durchgang richtung
toilette das war relativ eng wir hatten
das auch noch nicht verputzt weil wir
nicht wussten was wir da hin machen
sollten und haben uns dann
schlussendlich mit dem glas auf die
türen gemacht hat zusammen getan und
gesagt das schlau wäre eine riesige
spiegel front hin zu machen damit können
wir den ja quasi schmalsten bereiche in
unserem büro um das doppelte verlängern
weil es einfach viel größer wirkt
dazwischen led streifen also haben wir
jetzt eine mit led streifen beleuchtet
spiegelwand vom boden quasi bis zu
decken
und jetzt aber zu einem absoluten
highlight unser kompletter lebensretter
viele von euch hat uns in der planung
schon angemerkt und zwar auch bewusst
dass wir etwas tun müssen die komplette
belüftung und klimatisierung unseres
büros wir haben fenster zur seite große
fenster also wirklich vom boden bis nach
ganz oben ist gaddafi nicht rein aber
dadurch auch hitze wir haben oberlichter
von oben knallt also auch die sonne
drauf und heißt es auch auf der
streaming raum hat kein einziges fenster
allgemein war klar dass was passieren
muss wer uns mit der firma nordhoff
zusammengetan den absoluten vollprofi es
auf diesem segment haben was
ausgerechnet geplant und sind angerückt
um drei tage hier komplett vollgas zu
geben und unser büro perfekt zu
klimatisieren max hatte die ganze
baustelle im blick und hat darauf
geachtet dass alles mit rechten dingen
zugeht es ist montagmorgen dave ist auf
dem weg aus berlin nach köln das
verspreche ich euch der ganze innenhof
steht voll mit autos von nord-soft denn
wir kriegen heute unsere klimaanlagen
ist es so krass was das für ein aufgebot
ist wir haben so viele geräte insgesamt
sechs stück in den innenräumen drei tage
umbau wird das ganze noch mal
weitermachen und wir nehmen euch ein
bisschen mit dem prozess so ein ding
steht dann später auf dem dach von hier
drinnen werden die leitung in den raum
rhein geführt und das macht die magie
ist ja auch nicht so läuten werden wir
sind unser von oben aus acht
[Musik]
durch wunderschön ich noch die einzige
sparte
wenn sie sie bildwürdig aus aber es
schon schlauer für die anderen weiß
geräte gewährt dabei im raum hätte das
sogar auch aktiv in das ist ein
richtiger
endlich gut auf
eine küche
[Musik]
also jetzt auf dem ersten tag umbau
meine erste reaktion auf unsere
klimaanlage
er ist komplett im trockenbau fällt kein
einziges kabel kostet greifen weil man
nicht so gut gemacht dass die uns kanäle
mit eingelegt hamburger potenziell auch
noch amerika waren können wir jetzt da
können wir führung kann er komplett
benutzen alles klappt so aufgabe rein
was zufällig
tag nummer zwei es geht weiter ich bin
nicht allein heute geht's an den
streaming raum und noch viele weitere
sachen sehr wichtigster warum
wahrscheinlich werde ich mit klimaanlage
winzig klein rechner eigene körperwärme
also wird's richtig schnell richtig war
und jetzt wurden schon die vorkehrung
auf dem dach getroffen und heute wird
und auch hier in den raum noch die
anlage installiert ziemlich schwierig
hier weil ich alles komisch wie
verputzen sondern kriegen wir jetzt
gehört
[Musik]
da dieses bereiches ist zu spüren ich
bin so was würde ich dann hält es nicht
aus eine
junior eday at
da kannst du nicht unterstellen ist
zugleich die ballers komplett und
wirklich heute ist ein tag der zeigt uns
wie kein anderer warum wird brauchen wir
sind nämlich auf keinen grünen zweig
gekommen wir saßen die ganzen tag im
büro wir konnten uns wirklich nicht
konzentrieren was ist das ist ein
gedanke dass sie jetzt drei tage bei uns
geholzt jemals weiter da zieht vor allen
dingen aus wie so ein ipad
desinfektionsspray trifft er nicht danke
von ganzem herzen
zum kompletten halle team 2 wir danken
weil ich wirklich von ganzem herzen
heute ist der erste tag war ich gemerkt
haben die kraft das ist das paar zu
haben werden soll hat in jedem
freunde nordhoff hat hier bei uns so
basiert fünf sterne unglaublicher
service unglaublich arbeit kein einziges
kabel alles klinge laufen anfrage
unseres vermieters noch extra mega den
aufwand gemacht und was alles hier
richtig richtig gut gemacht dass eine
bewertung dar und unterstützt dort hofft
fünf sterne trägt er auch von mir
dankeschön für alles
[Applaus]
diese klimaanlage hat uns in den letzten
tagen und wochen schon so krass den
arsch gerettet wir waren drei tage so
drei tage an den 25 grad war ohne
klimaanlage hier unterwegs es war
komplett hölle so hölle dass max und ich
gesagt habe wir können nicht arbeiten
sind eine stunde raus gegangen haben uns
mega viel wasser reingepresst aber das
ist natürlich langfristig nicht die
lösung so können wir jetzt unser büro
auf einem schmalen weg übers handy die
ganze zeit perfekt kontrollieren und
klimatisieren das ist megageil wir sind
mega dankbar und vor allem sicher
dankbar dass die nord auf jungs so super
professionell und gleichzeitig so
sympathisch waren dass wir über die
kompletten drei tagen wo wir das büro
hier mit denen umgebaut haben auch immer
nach der arbeitszeit noch unterwegs
waren also eine absolute empfehlung wenn
ihr klima mäßig irgendwas braucht dann
ist nordhoff der richtige
ansprechpartner für euch dafür sind auch
alle links navi die beschreibung ja und
wenn ich es richtig im kopf hab läuft
sogar gerade noch ein gewinnspiel bei
max auf dem instagram kanal mit nordhoff
zusammen bei dem eine klimaanlage plus
einbau deutschlandweit gewinnen könnt
also check ist aus macht mit und genießt
die sommertage in einem wohl
klimatisierten raum all in all bin ich
unglaublich happy mit unserem buch jeden
tag komme ich hier rein und erfreue mich
daran dass wir so viel platz haben dass
es so gut durchdacht ist dass ich habe
keine stelle mehr die mich richtig
abfahrt außer die kirche wo wir jetzt
eine gute überbrückungslösung gefunden
haben aber langfristig wird es natürlich
noch cooler wenn max super mega küche da
rein kommt und wir hier wirklich einmal
komplett starten können einweihungsfeier
machen können aber es ist ein absoluter
traum vielen dank dass ihr möglich macht
dass wir uns so was verwirklichen können
und von hier aus coole videos für euch
produzieren cous cous cous vergesst
nicht die video like dazu lassen
vergessen nicht den kanal zu abonnieren
um das wohnungsbauprojekt nicht zu
verpassen wir sehen uns am sonntag schon
wieder zum nächsten höhle der löwen
video nächsten donnerstag gibt's dann
glaube ich dass erste wohnungs video und
ich wünsche euch ein schönes wochenende